at a security summit in singapore the
most highly anticipated speaker of the
three-day conference took the stage with
forceful words
we do not bully others
but we will not allow ourselves to be
bullied but if anyone dares to attack us
the people's liberation army will not
hesitate to fight back
a short speech that covered a range of
regional flashpoints
we will resolutely crush any attempt to
pursue taiwan independence if anyone
dares to secede taiwan from china we
will not hesitate to fight
we will fight at all costs
analysts say wei fung hua has made
beijing's priorities clear he wanted to
talk to his audience about what they're
doing in asia what they expect over
taiwan and why the united states is
actually responsible in china's eyes for
the instability in this region
in his speech we framed washington as a
meddling power one that tries to create
instability in the asia pacific or in
his words one that tries to hijack
countries in the region to create
division
in contrast wei says china's military is
a force for peace
[Music]
australia's new defence minister has
told al jazeera there are many questions
that need answers
we are seeing a very significant build
up by china
it's the biggest military buildup that
we've seen in the world since the end of
the second world war
and it's really important that that
occur in a transparent way the pacific
has also been a topic of discussion at
the summit and following increased
engagement from beijing
richard miles says australia is
revitalizing its relations with those
countries if we go out into the pacific
island countries do the work uh place
their interests at the centre of our
engagement
then the rest takes care of itself we
will become the natural partner of
choice we are thankful for this
opportunity fiji's defense minister one
of the few representatives from the
pacific fielded questions about his
region's ties to beijing
meeting with the chinese of course
everybody's knows that we met the
americans
we met the japanese
we met the chinese we met the
australians you name it
as organizers wrap up this year's summit
uncertainty over the region's future
remains intended to provide diplomatic
avenues to help solve differences it's
also provided delegates the chance to
wear their grievances for the world to
see jessica washington al jazeera
singapore now earlier we spoke to mia
newens who's from the international
institute for strategic studies she says
a china stance on
taiwan is clear
i think with regards to taiwan in
particular what we saw from general wei
fungha
and state council
was a reiteration of china's stance on
the issue of taiwan and taiwanese
independence i think in some ways that
was a reaction of course to what we
heard from president biden a few weeks
ago in terms of question of whether or
not the united states would intervene
militarily in a taiwan scenario and
whether or not the united states had
moved on from its strategic ambiguity
with regards to its stance on taiwan and
general austin of course said that um
strategic and well signaled that
strategic ambiguity hadn't changed and
of course that there was no support for
taiwan's independence um and that that
policy was still in place um but at the
end of the day i think general way and
china felt the need to re-emphasize
and restate how strong their feelings on
this point are what i found particularly
interesting though was that at the end
of talking about the us's position with
regards to taiwan there was a small
comment with regards to other countries
who might support taiwan as well and
that they will supposedly also not
succeed
from general waste perspective and that
i think pointed to perhaps other
countries in the region or abroad the
concept here is really that the u.s has
no say in the region extra regional
countries as china calls them aren't
here to determine regional security and
that it's up to countries within the
region to determine that of course the
countries within the region also have an
interest in having extra regional
countries and the united states present
and active and engaged in the region as
well so there's a contradiction there